[Applauso]
vi siete mai sentiti giudicati per la
musica che ascoltate la musica è da
sempre uno strumento di dialogo uno
strumento di conoscenza delle diverse
identità culturali venne usata dagli
artisti per esprimere un'idea
un'opinione
una scelta di vita o anche semplicemente
per raggiungere la famo la ricchezza
oggi sono qui per parlarvi di come il
nostro subconscio ci porti ad ascoltarvi
un centro un certo genere in base al
nostro carattere e di come ciò purtroppo
abbia portato una specie di pregiudizio
musicale
recentemente ho letto una ricerca sulla
correlazione tra carattere e musica
condotta dal professor adrian nord
dell'air ott watt university di
edimburgo
dato il carattere sperimentale ed
empirico della ricerca
onestamente mi sento anch'io parte di
questa fase di indagine su questo
argomento in quanto fruitore e allo
stesso tempo produttore di musica perché
sono un musicista da ben 9 anni e da
questa mia passione è nato questo
interesse per questa particolare
sfumatura
a primo impatto può sembrare banale ma
che in realtà nasconde molte
implicazioni legate all'ambito
psicologico sociale e anche culturale
facendo una ricerca su 36 mila soggetti
questo professore ha deciso di associare
a un certo tipo di musica un
corrispettivo carattere o una
corrispettiva personalità ad esempio che
ascolta la musica classica risulta
essere una persona molto creativa dolce
rilassata e con un'alta autostima che
ascolta la musica heavy metal secondo il
professore risulta essere una persona
dolce creativa rilassata e con una bassa
autostima
chi invece ascolta la musica dance
risulta essere una persona molto
creativa ma chi non è dove c'è quelle
persone questo professore spiega come
non sia la musica a creare il nostro
carattere
ma come ben si sia il nostro carattere
a spingerci a scegliere un certo tipo di
musica così da stare bene con noi stessi
e con gli altri e molte volte noi stessi
ci stupiamo di come il nostro dito che
ne ha tratto
alla luce di ciò possiamo dire come la
musica sia uno strumento che ci dà
tranquillità serenità
oppure un qualcosa che ci aiuta a
fuggire da questo mondo e a rinchiuderci
in una nostra propria realtà la società
così frenetica e superficiale tende ad
etichettarci dandoci dei ruoli fissi
appunto le maschere che pirandello
identificava con la forma esterna ma
dentro c'è un fiume dei cambiamenti
interni
io non ho una sola identità ma più
identità che coesistono insieme e la
musica è espressione di questo gustav
jung sosteneva come la personalità è un
insieme di energie influenzato anche
dalle energie esterne che vanno a
definire la personalità stessa la musica
è una di queste energie esterne che va a
completare la nostra personalità ma non
ne determina l'insieme analizzando la
parola pregiudizio possiamo dire come
essa sia un'opinione preconcetta capace
di far assumere comportamenti ingiusti
nell'ambito del giudizio e dei rapporti
sociali
per chi non avesse capito bene questa
definizione molto semplicemente il
pregiudizio è un giudizio una critica
ho un'opinione che si dà su una
determinata cosa o persona prima di
conoscerla a fondo in questo secolo si è
potuto vedere come piano piano sia tra
jaga i ragazzi che gli adulti si sia
formato una sorta di pregiudizio
musicale in breve le persone
preferiscono giudicare il comportamento
poi l'atteggiamento o la personalità di
una persona in base alla musica che
ascolta invece di conoscere la prima a
fondo per addentrarci nell'argomento
vorrei parlarvi dell'aspetto
caratteriale o meglio della personalità
che ognuno di noi ha la personalità è
l'insieme delle caratteristiche
psichiche e delle modalità
comportamentali che definiscono le
differenze tra noi esseri umani
secondo gli psicologi questa personalità
si va a formare nel corso degli anni in
diverse fasi della nostra vita
tra le quali abbiamo la prima infanzia e
adolescenza la vita adulta e anche
l'anzianità e ciò è possibile attraverso
un susseguirsi di fatti eventi o azioni
che vanno a modificare i nodi cruciali
della mente così da raggiungere una
specie di maturità psicofisica
chiamiamola avendo preso questa premessa
vorrei parlarvi di uno dei generi
musicali ancora non studiato dal
professor nord più discusso al giorno
d'oggi la trap
nata nel sud degli stati uniti
questa questo genere è considerato un
sottogenere dell'hip hop il termine trap
deriva da tra house i quali erano
edifici abbandonati dove gli spacciatori
creavano e commercializzavano sostanze
stupefacenti si è diffusa in tutti gli
stati uniti e nel 2010 ha fatto il boom
anche in europa
in paesi come francia germania e anche
italia
questo genere è molto diffuso tra tutti
i giovani è caratterizzato da parole
scurrili che definiscono una vita
utopistica fatta di sesso droga vestiti
firmati e denaro
va però detto che molti artisti hanno
ammorbidito i loro testi un esempio da
lì con il suo singolo cara italia uscito
nel 2018
molte persone criticano profondamente
questo genere e chi lo segue ma se ci
pensa che se ci pensate
nel corso del tempo molti artisti hanno
volutamente proposto è vissuto in prima
persona uno stile di vita fuori dalle
regole dalle convenzioni un esempio su
tutti i poeti maledetti che hanno fatto
della sregolatezza
una scelta di vita per esprimere un
disagio verso la società e questa
struggle atetsa molte volte si traduceva
con l'abuso di alcol droga e nella
ricerca di esperienze intense così da
evocare sensazioni e situazioni estreme
eppure i testi usciti dalla penna dalla
penna di berline di limbo solo una
preziosissima manifestazione artistica
perché l'arte e la vita vengono esaltati
attraverso dei simboli che vanno a
coinvolgere l'animo umano nelle sue
emozioni e nei suoi desideri più
inconsci questo riferimento letterario
vuole aiutare a far capire che magari
anche chi fa musica trap non sempre
manda un messaggio che è quello
letterale
va però detto che la trap fa parte
dell'insieme della musica commerciale
in poche parole di quei generi che usano
tutti i tipi di testi tutti i tipi di
ritmi e tutti i tipi di immagini pur di
stare in cima alla classifica
prendendo in considerazione ciò che
abbiamo detto prima
abbiamo capito che la musica non creava
personalità di una persona ma bensì
battere o la personalità che ci spinge a
scegliere un certo tipo genere di musica
non ha senso per giudicare una persona
per la musica che ascolta non ha senso
pregiudicarla per la sua personalità
tanto meno le azioni che questa persona
possa compiere anche nel caso della trap
non sempre chi ascolta questo genere
musicale fa sempre le cose che dicono
ovvio non dico che non ci sarà il
ragazzo sfrenato e dissoluto da chi
ascolta questa canzone
ma se ci pensate c'è anche tra chi
ascolta la musica dance
la musica techno la musica blues
anche la musica classica perché dico
questo perché le nostre azioni non sono
determinate dalla musica che ascoltiamo
ma bensì da un carattere che sia dato a
formare durante gli anni ma adesso che
ci penso e se lo avete notato anche voi
con il termine il ragazzo sfrenato e
dissoluto ho dato anche un etichetta
questo ragazzo che ascolta questa
canzone o questo genere di musica ma
finalmente posso correggerli e spero che
anche la società lo faccia così da
essere meno superficiale la trap sta
cavalcando l'onda del successo e questo
può essere un'opportunità per tutti noi
di cambiare modo di pensare di
scardinare una consuetudine negativa di
etichettare gli ascoltatori
e ricordate non vi sentite giudicati per
la musica che ascoltate non giudicate
gli altri per la musica che ascoltano
perché la passione per quel genere viene
da dentro
da una parte di voi che cerca di
esprimersi e tutto quello che fa la
musica è semplicemente accoglierà se
quel desiderio di espressione interiore
che vostro essere chiede e vi saluto con
una frase che disse emil cioran
o cosa faccia riferimento la musica e
noi è difficile da capire
si sa solo che tocca una zona così
profonda che la stessa pazzia non può
penetrarvi grazie
[Applauso]